[Music]
uh well did you have you seen this
buster rhymes video no bro this is wild
this is from
five days ago so he was doing a concert
whatever i forget where he was at
and i don't need to explain it to you
you just need a watch
[Music]
the only thing oh sorry the only thing
to point out is
just keep an eye on his hand okay
[Music]
that woman's trying to touch him stop
the music
back up
back
what kind of [ __ ] you wanna let her
continue to grab me up
imagine looking up and that's what you
see
[Applause]
i'm a grown man i'll [ __ ] your girl bro
look at the guy look at the guy look at
the girl oh my god
can i say i i'm on bus the bus to rhyme
side here i think he's absolutely a
little bit too old-school school for
this world
yeah
but i love you love seeing it right oh
yeah i love seeing it i think this was
in orlando look i like bass black there
was this in orlando because the guy's
wearing a magic shirt
and it's a white guy so you know it's
not because of fashion
that's right because he's a fan oh no
this is a weird thing
[Music]
and i don't agree with that she might do
some police [ __ ] i'm not willing
she ain't for my day
my time we didn't [ __ ] with all these
cameras
have your girls stand behind you bro
stand behind
and what you caught at the end of the
video was first starting to stand behind
him
so what are we thinking marsh
what are we thinking i'm thinking busta
rhymes is a [ __ ]
absolute [ __ ]
based
red pills
dude he's been a [ __ ] legend lately
actually he's been the other one that
was talking [ __ ] about the vax and stuff
yeah he was it was funny he was at the
scene of a shooting in new york
oh yeah yeah and it was like the
weirdest article ever because they were
like shooting on like 34th street busta
rhymes appears
and it was like
you could just tell they didn't want to
write two different stories but it was
like there was some club party
and then like i guess after the shooting
a bunch of people keep like you know
people somebody got shot outside he just
happened to be in a club and him and his
friends were just came outside to look
and they were like
well it's boring it's just some rando
got shot by some rando we got to spice
it up buster rhymes was there all right
give me a picture give me art
and we'll add a little picture of busta
rhymes standing there bewildered on a
cell phone and then that like the
article almost like the headline makes
it seem like buster rhymes was involved
in the shooting well yeah but of course
they do that though so you so you oh and
you read it and then you're like wait so
busta runs just happened to be at this
party and came outside like every other
[ __ ] lookie-loo